hello fellow Guardians destiny too has
been out for just a few days but we got
our first exotic gun guide for you we'll
be coming out with more so make sure to
give us a sub for more destiny 2 guides
to get the sturm exotic hand cannon you
have to finish the campaign first then
head to necess to get the quest Oh
captain my captain at exodus black near
failsafe get through the steps required
for the Oh captain my captain mission
and you'll receive a shiny drag sidearm
for your troubles after that you'll get
a request to talk to Rahul you'll then
need to decrypt five legendary engrams
one exotic Engram and killed 10 fallen
on neces with drink hopefully your luck
is good and you get an exotic Engram
head back and talk to Rahul once you've
done all these steps he'll then send you
to the farm to talk to tira Karn she'll
then want you to head to necess and kill
ten fallen without reloading it's not so
strict as to have you killing ten in a
row without reloading so kill two or
three then reload rinse repeat until
you've killed ten she'll want you to
kill ten powerful fallen on necess using
drink I found that being in the exodus
black area was the easiest as a high
valued captain would spawn about every
five to seven minutes I just farmed the
area and did public events until I saw
the captain once done head back to tier
carne and she'll have you do one more
thing you'll need to head into a strike
on necess and kill the servitor
Kendricks
seven once killed talk to Tara Karn for
your brand new Sturm handcannon exotic
the cool thing about Sturm and Drang is
that when you get kills on either gun
it'll reload the opposite basically
making it so you don't have to reload a
fun new weapon combo system in destiny -
a protip here would be to wait to get to
your highest power level before turning
this in as you can see I've got a 280
sturm exotic hand cannon we have more
destiny two guys coming down the
pipeline so make sure to subscribe so
you know when those hot guides are
coming out see you guys next time
[Music]